okay a few a few others on this call and
meeting I've also worked on a primarily
based out of the Illinois instituted
psychology down by the the Sox stadium
and uh as mentioned I'm a PhD student in
Applied Mathematics I've been working on
the software for a number of years so
today I want to kind of go over the
basics I gave a talk a couple years ago
regarding qmc pi and we went over you
know the basic structure there and today
I want to go back over that but also add
a little bit more on and some some newer
capabilities specifically focusing
around this Vector functions of multiple
integrals so what do we do when we have
quantities of interest that can be
formulated as multiple expectations or
more multiple integrals
so I'm actually going to skip to the end
here
um I'm going to start with a few slides
and then go over a demo at the end the
the demo is linked here at this
tinyurl.com qmc Pi Pi data Chicago chai
2023 and it should bring you to a collab
notebook
that I'm showing here and if you want to
maybe maybe run the if you want to
follow along you should run this first
few cells because they take a few
minutes so you could run those while
we're going over the slides and that way
if you want to follow along in your copy
and try out different parameters or make
any changes
um I think that'd be a nice way to
follow along if you're interested but
I'd suggest you run these first few
cells because it does take a bit bit to
install some things instead of so
okay
so what is Monte Carlo so so the basic
Monte Carlo problem here is we want to
approximate what we're going to call the
true mean so we have this in blue here
we call it mu and this can be formulated
as an expectation so the user gives you
some true measure which we'll call it t
we call this the original measure or the
true measure and then you know for
example this can be a normal or a
gaussian or some multi-dimensional
random variable and then we have some
function or simulation which we call G
and this is the original integrand so
our quantity of interest is the
expectation of G the original integrand
of T the original or true measure
now T can be sometimes hard to sample
from but we we know how to draw samples
from a standard uniform in D Dimensions
so you want to perform a change of
variables to have our quantity of
Interest be formulated as an expectation
with respect to a standard uniform in D
dimensions
so we make this change of variables here
between these two expectations so now we
have mu is equal to the expectation of f
which is going to be some transformed
integrand of X which X is always our
transform measure which is always a
standard uniform in D Dimensions because
we know how to sample that well
this last equality just writes out this
expectation as an integral so that's
kind of our connection here when we say
integrals and expectations we're kind of
talking about the same thing here
so again we have original measure
original integrand We perform a change
of variables we get a transform measure
and transformed into Grand now we'll
mostly be working with this last form
here but it's important to know that you
can perform this change of variables so
if you have you know Randomness that
isn't a standard uniform you can always
get it into this nice format
okay so Monte Carlo is interested in
approximating this this unknown mean so
how does it do that well we make we get
an approximation of the sample mean
which is you know maybe the most natural
approximation so we draw a bunch of
nodes here we take end nodes they're
index from zero here so x0 through x n
minus 1 these end nodes you evaluate
your transformed integrand at these
uniform nodes and then you simply take
the sample average pretty
straightforward so there's two different
flavors here
um that we've implemented into qmc pi
and I want to talk a bit about the
differences here so the first flavor is
what we call a crude Monte Carlo
um
so this is going to take your your end
nodes to be IID points they're
independent and identically distributed
and because they're independent there's
going to be some gaps in clustering of
points because the points don't have
knowledge of one another
this is in contrast to quasi Monte Carlo
where we carefully coordinate the points
to have these dependent sequences of
points that have give you more even
coverage and try to avoid gaps and
clusterings and we'll see some pictures
of that later on
now the rate of convergence of crude
Monte Carlo when we're using these IID
points is one over the square root of n
compared to quasimante Carlo which
achieves a rate of rate about one over n
so it's going to be significantly faster
now the caveat
is that crude Monte Carlo is going to
work for a much larger class of
integrands quasim Monte Carlo is only
theoretically advantageous for a smaller
set of integrands which depend on you
know only a few Dimensions so you might
have a hundred dimensional problem but
if it really only depends on a few key
Dimensions or a few key combinations of
dimensions then quasi Monte Carlo can
provide you a large advantage and even
for problems where it's not necessarily
theoretically advantageous we still
often see that quasi Monte Carlo
outperforms Monte Carlo so you can often
the key takeaway here is you can get
some nice savings and a much better
approximation with the same number of
samples Often by just swapping in these
low discrepancy sequences and we'll see
this in the demo later on
so this is just a basic setup we have a
true mean it's an expectation we
approximate it by a sample mean we could
pick the points to be IID and do crew
Monte Carlo which is generally a bit
slower than
um quasi Monte Carlo
okay so how have we
um
put this this problem into components
and how if we made it into a software
so we we've made what we call this qmc
Pi software quasi Monte Carlo software
and python
and we've broke it down into four main
components each of these components is
implemented as an abstract class and
then the abstract class has
um child classes which flesh out the
attributes of the abstract class
into a specific instance
and then you initialize these objects
and you fit them together and this will
all make more sense when to go over a
demo later on
but our first object is going to be this
discrete distribution and this is really
a generator of our our samples or our
sequence so it's going to generate your
sampling locations x0 X1 through x n
minus one and maybe you want to increase
that and so it should be able to give
you as many samples as you like up to
you know some some large enough
threshold
your true measure is really for defining
your problem this is the measure that
your original integrand is defined with
respect to so you have your true measure
this is the T that we talked about
earlier and what this is going to do is
going to allow us to choose a
transformation automatically for the
user so we can write mu equal to f of x
so once you define t
then we know how to make this
transformation
now the integrand is where we Define
this G the original integrand and
because it knows about the true measure
it can actually store information about
this transform function f as well
and our last component here is the
stopping Criterion so this is going to
adaptively increase n until our
approximation of this true mean is
sufficiently close to the to the true
mean so you may think you know with this
setup maybe you just pick a fixed then
you have a budget of how many times you
want to evaluate the function
and this gives you a good enough
approximation we kind of take a
different view that maybe you have your
problem and you know say you're trying
to estimate a stock price and you want
to know
um when your estimation is to within one
penny of the the true you know the true
payoff of this option or some Financial
derivative so you're going to give us
this Epsilon this tolerance this this
one Petty threshold and we're going to
to adaptively increase the number of
samples into our approximation is within
this air tolerance of the true mean
based on you know some assumptions on
the integral or um you know some some
confidence threshold that you'll also
specify so we can get some some notion
of this error and you give us a
threshold and we increase the samples
until this threshold to met
foreign
things I've talked about in the previous
talk but this talk I want to emphasize
one more thing here which is this
vectorized topping Criterion idea
so previously we had a scalar quantity
of Interest this mu it's just a single
number now your quantity of Interest as
you know it's still a scalar but now it
can be written as a combination of
multiple integrals or multiple
expectations so if s is C which is some
function combining mu zero mu 1 mu 2 a
series of of these means so for example
in a very simple example we have two
random variables Y and Z if we want to
approximate their covariance we would
write this covariance as this
expectation minus the product of these
two expectations here so this mu zero is
this expectation of the product of mu 1
and mu 2 are the individual expectations
of these random variables
so this is our s here our quantity of
interest is the covariance and it's
written in terms of these three
expectations
another example in Bayesian statistics
you have a posterior mean we can write
this as the ratio of two expectations in
terms of this prior and this likelihood
integrals which give you your integral
form here
and sensitivity indices are quite
popular for quantifying the importance
of different inputs to the variability
in the output of a simulation so it
gives you kind of a important score for
different subsets of your inputs and
this can also be formulated as
expectations it's a bit too complicated
for this this one slide but we have it
implemented and we'll see a nice example
of that later on
so what we've done you know from the
previous talks now one of our major
upgrades is that we now have enabled an
Adaptive approximation of this s hat
this combined quantity of interest in
terms of multiple expectations
without you get an Adaptive
approximation of this to within some air
tolerance instead of just you know your
scalar single expectation
okay so this this slide I showed earlier
uh we'll now move over to a demo of this
software again this is at tinyurl.com
qmc Pi Pi data chai 2023 if you're
interested in following along I can also
make these slides public so that this
link will always be there if you want a
nice starting place for learning qmc Pi
software and and using some of the tools
we go over today
they also have a home page here at
qmcpi.org I'll show that in a minute and
we have this basic article
um reference one this goes over
everything I just talked about except
the vectorized stopping Criterion
there'll be a you know another paper
hopefully coming out sometime later this
year that discusses these vectorized
stopping Criterion in more detail when I
could share a link when that's published
but this this will go over about 90 of
what we talk about today minus the
vectorized stopping Criterion and this
reference two is a book Monte Carlo
methods by Art Owen that that I find
that I found quite helpful in in you
know learning some more the the math and
the background behind this Monte Carlo
and it even has a nice appendix
discussing sensitivity indices if that's
something you're interested in as well
so I'll now move over to our demo
um unless there's any questions
take the second your
if if not
um
this is our qmcpi.org it's a home page
for our qmc PI software
um you have a number of blogs which go
over the background on a lot of the the
qmc pi methods and you know the idea how
about hand quality Monte Carlo and some
of the specific ideas that we've
implemented into these classes we have
documentation here on read the docs
which talks about each of the components
and then we also have a demo section
here at the bottom which has a number of
Jupiter notebooks that are rendered into
documentation to look over
is easy to install you just pip install
a qmc PI from from Pi Pi here
and we have a GitHub page qmc software
qmc software if you're interested in
that
so all these are linked right off all
these are linked off of qmcpi.org
including the article I mentioned here
okay so now let's move over into this
demo here this is our Monte Carlo for
Vector functions of integral this is on
Google collab so there should be no real
setup necessary
um if you're running this for the first
time
sorry if you're running this for the
first time this first cell is going to
take a bit to run because it has to
install latex we use latex to render
some of the the labels in our images so
we set up latex in this first cell don't
worry too much about it but it will take
a minute to run here
um but that's just so we can get math
notation in our pictures
uh here we install qmc Pi into the
collab notebook it's as simple as this
um you may want to make sure you have
this
1.3.3.1 that'll get you all the latest
features and make sure that everything
can run
nicely
so I'll run this along along with us
here
so you start by I've already installed
it so it should just already have it
there and then we're going to use a few
key packages here we're going to import
qmc pi as QP so this is going to be our
Alias for all the qmc pi components
we're going to import numpy as NP
um you know that's pretty standard use
scipy pandas matplotlib and time to do a
bit of timing
um yeah the rest of this is pretty
standard so we start by importing these
packages
so now we're going to go over a few
components the first component
being that discrete distribution so this
is again going to generate our sampling
locations
let me just go back to the top again we
have our true mean our original
integrand of our original measure t or a
true measure we transform this to get it
our transformed it to Grant f with
respect to our transform measure the
standard uniform and then we approximate
this by the sampling mean of the sample
mean of nodes drawn from this uniform
uniform distribution
so our first component is this discrete
distribution which is going to generate
these nodes
so in the simplest case again we're
using these IID nodes and this is
corresponding to crude Monte Carlo
um we're going to start by just defining
a discrete distribution we'll just call
it IID and this is our qmc pi.iid
standard uniform and we pass in
dimension is three and then we call gen
samples and we get four samples so this
returns a four by three array of samples
here
and if we ask for four more samples it's
going to give us four different samples
again in this four by three numpy array
um a nice thing about qmc Pi is you can
always print the objects and it should
give you some nice a nice summary of the
information here this D is the dimension
it's three entropy is like a a seed for
your for the randomness and spawn key is
not something you have to worry about
so it's IID generator is no more
complicated than you know
numpy.random.rand where it just gives
you random samples in fact this is just
a wrapper around that generator so this
is pretty simple
and we now move to a more complicated
example the syntax isn't more
complicated but the Thunder line
generator is here a little more involved
because we're generating low discrepancy
points again these are carefully
coordinated points that we're using
they're causing Monte Carlo
so in the same fashion we call QP dot
lattice lattice is the name of the
generator for a load of discrepancy
sequence and we're getting a
three-dimensional lattice and we take
the first four points here
so you draw those and we draw another
four points but now you notice that
these four points are the exact same as
the previous four points and that that's
an important difference here is our IID
generators each time we call them they
give us you know a new set of ID points
low discrepancy points the low
discrepancy generators give you a
sequence so if you ask for Four Points
you ask for another four points it's
going to always be giving you the first
four points in that sequence if you want
to get
you know points later in the sequence
you have to specify the indices so it's
the same as python indexing two is
inclusive four is exclusive so when we
do this
we get the last two points in this
sequence and you notice that they match
these points right here
similarly you could put four to eight to
get the next four points in the sequence
it's important to notice that when
you're drawing more points you need to
index these sequences accordingly for
for low discrepancy points
again we can print out the low
discrepancy generator object here which
shows it's a lattice which is a discrete
distribution object of the discrete
distribution abstract class the lattice
subclass
three dimensions you're using the first
three dimensions of the lattice
generator
um we've randomized and we always like
to randomize our our design so that
points don't lie on the boundary in one
dimension you don't want to point out
one or zero because then when you're
running through these transforms for
example the inverse CDF of a gaussian if
you run your your point at zero through
that inverse CDF it's going to map to
negative infinity and this is going to
be problematic in your simulations so we
like to randomize to avoid having those
points lie on the boundaries and also
maintain this nice structure of these
low discrepancy designs
so this like so we we just finally get
this visual comparison of IID versus low
discrepancy points so you define four
objects here we have our IID one which
we saw or lattice which we saw and then
two other low discrepancy generators
and you can see them visualized along
the bottom here
um you take two to the seventh point so
128 points in each of these and on the
left we get these IID points which have
many gaps and clusterings because again
they're independent so you know there's
nothing preventing one point from
falling right next to another Point
whereas we carefully coordinate these
low discrepancy designs so they they
have better space filling properties and
in fact we've chosen a power of two
because this lattice and digital net
will have will attain their their nice
space filling properties at powers of
two
Halton also has nice num nice uh
preferred numbers but they're quite
infrequent so
let's not worry about that for right now
the key takeaway here is that these low
discrepancy designs they they fill the
space better they're more even and
they're more uniform in a sense
so another thing to talk about is this
extensibility our stopping Criterion are
going to want to iteratively increase
the sample size and iteratively double
the sample size often
until your your air tolerance is met
so to do that we need sequences which
are extensible and extensibility means
that as you double the the sample size
or as you increase the sample size you
fill in the gaps left by the the earlier
points in the sequence so for IID this
doesn't make a whole lot of sense I mean
obviously you can always get more IID
points but they're not necessarily going
to fill in the space better because they
continue to be independent whereas this
lattice you notice if we start with the
you start with the 64 Blue Points index
0-64 and then we get the next 64 points
index 64 to 128 and we color those in
pink
and then we get you know index 128 to
256 and we color those in green every
time we add every time we double the
point size we're filling in the gaps
left by the the previous points and the
same idea holds for this digital map
with this Halton as well
um
and again we want to use these powers of
2 so that we we fully fill in all the
gaps otherwise you're not using powers
of two you might miss a point one of
these pink points along the bottom or
one of these Blue Points so you want to
get that most uniform coverage so we'd
like like to use powers of two for our
Point size for this lattice and digital
nut
and again you see the the much better
space filling properties of these low
discrepancy sequences
now another nice plot
is we don't always want to generate
two-dimensional sequences so you know
here we have a four dimensional sequence
and it's helpful to visualize the
pairwise points here across Dimensions
so we have this you know triangle of
these different pairwise plots we see we
still get some pretty nice
stratification here but you notice that
you know even in this moderator
Dimensions some of the the pairwise
plots aren't so good like this one has a
clear pattern to it and there's these
large gaps and you can say that there
are some clusterings along here
um so this kind of gives us a just a
little bit of intuition as to why
causing Monte Carlo is so good for for
these low Dimensions where we can
stratify very well but it's hard to even
design these sequences where they'll
have all their pairwise projections have
nice uniformity so it starts to break
down at some point so there is that
trade-off again you know having your ID
points which are always going to have
gaps and clusters but consistently it
cost Dimensions versus low discrepancy
points which we can stratify pretty
nicely up to some extent to where we
have to accept some patterns in these
pair wiser higher dimensional subsets
here
so that's all I wanted to say here about
discrete distributions or these
generators move on to this next
component which is the true measure so
we'll start with this discrete
distribution dot Halton so we initialize
the discrete distribution and then we
create our true measure so in this case
we just have a gaussian with this mean
one two and three and then the
covariance is
going to be four or five and six along
the diagonal so these are independent
marginals here so we Define our true
measure
now we can sample from the true measure
by calling true measure.gen samples so
it'll generate four samples from the
Halton and then run them through a
transform so that they mimic a gaussian
distribution in this case we're taking a
fine transformation after running the
inverse CDF of a standard normal on each
of these uniform points
um same as in the discrete distribution
case if you're using a discrete
distribution which is low discrepancy
it's treated as a sequence and you need
to be careful with the indexing because
you know your index two to four and it's
going to give you these last two points
so you need to treat it like a sequence
and again you can print your true
measure object it'll give you a mean in
this case the covariance you supplied
and then your decomposition type
which just specifies how we're
transforming the points
In This Cloud we we plot some draws from
some different true measures in this
first one we have a uniform but now it's
not in the unit cube it's not zero one D
instead we have a in the First Dimension
it's negative three to three and in the
second dimension it's negative two to
two so these points get transformed just
by you know shift just by scaling them
and shifting them a bit to become this
standard uniform
um we have the gaussian here this is
just a standard gaussian in two
Dimensions these are the points that
we've gotten from that transform here's
a more complicated gaussian with a mean
and then a covariance where it's not
independent marginals we have some
covariance here and you can see these
this gaussian as well at these points
transform from this digital net in base
two
and if you do have independent marginals
um we've opened up qmc pi to a lot of
different distributions available in
scipy Via this QP dot scipy wrapper you
pass in your discrete distribution and
then you can pass in a list of your
independent marginals so in this case
the First Dimension we treat it as a
beta and then the second dimension we
treat it as a gamma and then we can
generate points from this joint
distribution just knowing it's
independent marginals and scipy has many
different distributions so this this
allows you to have a great bit of
flexibility if you have independent
marginals of your true mushroom
another popular
um this true measure is Brownian motion
for a lot of financial options and a lot
of modeling these paths here so we have
this Brownian motion which gets
visualized a bit differently here
um
so again you pass in your discrete
distribution we just construct a default
Browning motion starts at zero there's
no drift and unit diffusion
so you can see these paths here 32 paths
and 365 Dimensions so each Dimension is
a monitoring time of this Brownian
motion so we monitor it daily for a year
for example
um
and on this bottom plot we have a
brownie motion with some different
parameters here we now start the brownie
motion at five it has a drift downwards
so it's negative one so the pads kind of
tend to be going downwards
um and we have a diffusion parameter so
the pads tend to spread out quite a bit
as well and because we're using the same
underlying lattice the pads correspond
so this top Orange Path corresponds to
the same point as this top Orange Path
but under just a slightly different
transformation to accommodate these
different parameters similarly this
bottom Green Path is the same point as
this bottom Green Path here except for
they've undergone a different
transformation
so that's all about the true measures
um I'll talk about the integrand so this
is really the
the tree problem here
okay yes something in the chat but
okay it doesn't look like a question but
all right so this integrand is your your
function that you have that you want to
supply to qmc Pi and you supply it in
the form of G
so just a really simple example here so
your true measure is just a standard
normal and D dimensions and your G of T
just takes the sum of these standard
normals which we know the expectation of
this is just zero and in order to get it
into the nice format behind the scenes
qmc Pi is just going to take the inverse
CDF of a standard normal applied to this
uniform this is going to mimic
this standard normal
and this is our f of x this is the
transform that's done behind the scenes
so if you want to set this up in qmc pi
you first Define your integrand here to
call it my function
T is going to be an N by D numpy array
and samples D dimensions and we sum
across the First Dimension and return a
length and factor a function evaluations
really simple
now we specify our true measure here
which is going to be a gaussian and
again we need to choose the discrete
distribution sampler and we're going to
make it five-dimensional here so to tie
your function into qmc Pi you just call
qp.customfunction pass in your true
measure pass in your function and we
have a parallel argument which we leave
as false but if you want to easily
parallelize across multiple cores for
expensive problems you can set parallel
equal to true or even to an integer for
the number of cores but we won't go more
into that today
now we can evaluate the integrand by
um okay just to emphasize this is G this
is our original integrand and this is T
this is our original measure now what
we're going to do is we're going to drop
points from this transform measure we're
going to draw points from this discrete
distribution this uniform and we're
going to evaluate
your function dot f so it is transformed
into gram so this transform is done for
you behind the scenes you don't have to
worry about doing this transform you
just specify the you you specify the
true measure you specify your function
and we do the transform for you behind
the scenes
so you can evaluate your function here
just on these four points and you get
your y if you want to just make a manual
qmc approximation which you know we have
stopping Criterium which will do a lot
better for you but just to get an idea
for how you can do this you can draw
your points here so you draw points from
your halton.gen samples your discrete
distribution evaluate your function take
the mean and we see that it's pretty
close to zero so even with you know 2 to
the 16th points you've already gotten a
really good approximation here
um
we also have a number of
integrands that are already defined for
you in qmc pi for example this Asian
option is something it'll give something
interesting it'll give you the the fair
payoff of an Asian option in this case
we do weekly monitoring for a year so
there's 52 52 monitoring times of the
underlying true brownie emotion
and we specify a number of different
parameters here which you can see when
how they're set when we print this
object out and again you can do this
approximation just drawing points
evaluating your Instagram getting your
approximation and printing it out so the
fair value of this Asian option with
these parameters you know it's around a
dollar 79 or so
one one caveat here is this often Works
um you know for this simple setup we're
using a gaussian true measure there's a
single transform
we evaluate our integrand and our
approximation is this this weighted sum
with equal weights of one over n but
there's
um a flavor of Monte Carlo called
important sampling where you may perform
multiple transforms and then you need to
compensate the weights in some way in
order to keep this approximation
unbiased so just a little warning
um this will work in most cases if you
you know if you don't know what
important sampling is and you're not
you're probably not going to use it by
accident so this this will work but we
have nice stopping Criterion to give you
unbiased approximations which won't
necessarily use this equally weighted
average so this is more for illustration
purposes than something that you want to
do practically with qmc pi
does this thing get you into trouble
when you're doing important sampling
but
for what we've talked about today this
is this is good enough
so just to really drive home this point
about this transformation we visualize
it here for this simple example so you
have the keyster function here which is
shown on the left and then this is with
respect to the true measure which is the
gaussian so this is defined on the the
whole real line here
and you see the points here are drawn
from a gaussian this blue is the keister
function and the points are drawn from a
gaussian density this isn't the gaussian
density here this is the function in
blue and then these points are drawn
from a gaussian and we claim that under
the sampling the average height of this
function under this you know gaussian
sampling is equal to our transformed
integround on the right which now is
defined on zero to one and now we sample
uniformly so that's kind of the idea
behind this this transformation here not
something you necessarily need to worry
about because again that's going to be
done automatically for you in qmc pi
it does just really visualizes what's
going on behind the scenes and what the
difference is in this simple example
between the the original integrand and
the transformed integrand
Okay so we've talked about the discrete
distribution which is used to construct
the true measure which is to use to
describe construct the integrand now
we're going to go on to the really novel
uh part about qmc Pi which is our
stopping Criterion a lot of these other
components are available in you know
acipi High torch numb High even and it's
not that hard to you know get this
approximation on your own here but the
stopping Criterion are really the the
really unique part about qmc Pi in my
eyes where we adaptively increase the
sample size until our approximation is
below some tolerance
so to see this we start with this simple
Asian option and Sample so we start with
IID standard uniform points in 52
Dimensions It's weekly monitoring a
decision option for a year
uh we default to all other parameters of
this Asian option and then we plug it
into a qp.cube MCG so everything that
starts at cube is going to be a stopping
Criterion for a cubiture algorithm
we're going to be doing Monte Carlo or
crude Monte Carlo because we're using
IID points and we set an absolute
tolerance here of .025
here
so now we get an approximation and a
data object our approximation is just
going to be this scalar here but our
data object will be printed is going to
be give us a lot of a lot of information
so this first block is all the
information about what what happened
during the integration progress process
so you get in the solution an error
bounds
which matches our tolerance that was set
here we get the total number of samples
that was used around you know 324 000
samples and it took about 2.5 seconds
the rest of this are you know parameters
you've set like the absolute tolerance
or ones that got defaulted like the
relative tolerance and other algorithm
parameters like the the starting price
and the stock price that were defaulted
here as well
so this gives us online summary for the
street Monte Carlo but when we run quasi
Monte Carlo
we see that we get a solution of equally
high quality but in only a fraction of
the time and a fraction of the samples
again using the same tolerance and same
setup all we've done is swapped in a
load discrepancy generator this digital
net in base 2 and then we've chosen a
corresponding corresponding stopping
Criterion your stopping criteria needs
to match your point set so if you're
using IID points you need to use an IID
stopping Criterion if you're using a
digital net load discrepancy sequence
you need to use a digital net quasi
Monte Carlo stopping Criterion if you're
using a low discrepancy lattice you want
to use a quasi Monte Carlo lattice
cubature algorithm for stopping
Criterion 3.7 needs to match your
algorithm here
so from the previous example we've
swapped out the point set we stopped off
the algorithm kept all of their
parameters the same and now when we
integrate we notice that this only takes
around uh 2 000 samples
and the time to integrate is you know
less than 0.05 seconds compared to over
2.5 seconds for IID Monte Carlo
in fact quasi Monte Carlo took only 1.62
percent of the time and
.063 percent of the samples compared to
crude Monte Carlo
so we get huge savings when we're just
swapping in these low discrepancy points
and using a different algorithm to
achieve the same tolerance so this shows
really the advantage of causing Monte
Carlo
moreover you can decrease the tolerance
here
and we see how the algorithm responds in
terms of number of samples
and the time it takes to get a
sufficiently accurate approximation to
within this tolerance so as we go to the
right on these two plots we're
decreasing the tolerance
and you see that the number of samples
for IID Monte Carlo eventually goes to
this rate of around 1 over square root
of n whereas for quasim Monte Carlo you
see it only takes a fraction of time and
we get this much faster rate of around 1
over n here
now we do start off with this bit of a
flat part along the bottom here and this
is simply because our algorithm for
quasi Monte Carlo and Monte Carlo but
for causing Monte Carlo here is going to
have an initial number of samples and
what this is saying along this flat part
is that we don't need to progress Beyond
an initial sampling in order to get a
sufficient approximation so this flat
part we're just stuck at the initial
sampling but as we push the tolerance
lower and lower we end up needing more
and more samples So eventually we need
to increase this these sample sizes
which will increase the time as well
so again the key takeaway here is that
this quasi Monte Carlo is going to give
you a much better approximation in the
same amount of time or same number of
samples
and we see this across all problems
even ones where it's not necessarily
theoretically Justified we are seeing
great savings with quasi Monte Carlo so
it's it's definitely worth trying your
closing Monte Carlo algorithm on your
problem and getting significant Savings
in most cases
okay so now
the last couple minutes here we'll talk
about this this vectorized stopping
Criterion
um there's more examples in this
notebook but just as a simple example
here uh we'll we'll talk about Computing
two expectations simultaneously so one's
the product of the cosine of these of
each Dimension multiplied and the other
is the expectation of the sign
so now in a similar way we need to Nest
all of our constructions so we take our
stopping Criterion we pass in an
integrand which is a custom function we
pass in our true measure here which is
just this uniform up here
we're going to use a Halton low
discrepancy sequence for causing Monte
Carlo
we're going to Define our function which
just
now it takes an N by D array of samples
T and then returns an M by 2 Matrix or
array of samples First Column
corresponding to this product of cosines
and the second one corresponding to this
product of Sines
we have two individual Solutions we're
going to approximate and we set a pretty
low tolerance here
and you can see that we did a very good
approximation here to within the
tolerance in you know less than a second
here so it's it's really very efficient
to reuse these samples from the low
discrepancy sequence here and that's the
key is we we could just run this in a
for Loop you have multiple expectations
you can just run this in a for Loop but
by doing this you'll reuse those low
discrepancy points that you generated
and it'll be a bit faster here
instead of writing your own for Loop and
allocating different memory and
regenerating these points we could share
the point sets in a very natural way
with qmc pi just like this
so this is a pretty simple example we
just have two expectations
and a more nuanced example we have
um there are combined quantity of
interest is this covariance which we
talked about earlier it's formulated in
terms of these three expectations this
first one the second one and this third
one here
so now we can no longer use custom
function because we need to find a few
more things
um so we need to make an instance of
acute qmc Pi dot integrand integrand
abstract class
so we call this the covariance integrand
we start by taking in a discrete
distribution sampler we Define our true
measure here which in this example is a
gaussian
so for this example we have
T is a gaussian with mean one and
identity covariance and then we want to
compute the covariance of the product
and then the sum of across the
dimensions of this gaussian so we know
theoretically that this should be equal
to D
and
we'll see that the approximation tells
us that later on
so we start by defining G here so we
take in N by D array of samples we're
going to Output it n by three the First
Column is going to be
um this P the second the product the
second column is going to be the sum and
then the zeroth column is going to be
the product times the sum so this is the
zeroth column here sorry about that this
is the first column and then this is the
second column here
spawn just duplicates your object not
something super important but the key
here is that we can extend our previous
algorithms to this algorithm via
bounding function so if we have balance
on mu 0 and B1 and mu 2 we could
propagate those bounds onto the combined
solution
um by for example if we have bounds on
these variables what's the largest the
covariance could be well you take the
largest view zero can be minus the
smallest that the product of maybe one
and mu 2 can be assuming they're in
these bounds so that's what we've
defined here similarly
for the lowest well you'd minimize you'd
take the lower bound of this minus
um you know the the largest that the
product of either bound can be here so
we could propagate these bounds and then
we Define a dependency function as well
so we know that you know if we sample
you know this sufficiently well which
individual Solutions need to continue
being computed
so for example in this pre in this
previous example you'll notice that we
used a different number of samples to
compute the product of cosines versus
the product of science right
so it says
um this took around 262 000 this took
around 131 000 so after 131 000 samples
we added a sufficient approximation of
this product of Sines so we don't need
to sample this anymore and the compute
Flags here would tell us that if it's
you know if it's true then you need to
continue Computing the solution if not
you could ignore Computing it and save
some time
okay so in those covariance example the
true solution was 10 we get a very good
approximation our air bonds capture this
true mean so see that it works you use
just over a million points and then this
is the number of samples that were
required for each of the individual
Solutions and of course they all match
because you know if we need to continue
approximating the covariance then we
want to approximate each of these
individual Solutions more exactly
and this is pretty fast it's only about
five seconds to get a relative tolerance
here 0.025
so the final example here I've been
running out of time but we have
um you know a sensitivity into these
examples we want to
we'll start here by this popular data
set it's called the iris data set
so we're given attributes of an Irish
species uh there's three species here
and they have attributes such as the
Supple length Supple with petal length
and pedal width now we fit a neural
network to you know give us a surrogate
for the probability given some features
that it would lie to each of these three
species so the neural network you feed
it these four features and centimeters
and then it spits out three
probabilities which sum but one
corresponding to the probability of each
species
now this is a 98 accurate Network so we
say it's a good enough surrogate and we
now want to use that to get some
important scores
you know you could set this up like this
but I don't think I really have time to
go into this code the key here is that
we get something like this
so we can see how important are the
different features to the variability in
these probability scores so you can see
the pedal length is by far the most
important feature according to this
neural network for Qantas quantifying
the iris species from the from the
attributes so pedal line seems to be
most important but it's by far the most
important for a setosa a little less
important for virginica but even less
important for this Versa color you can
see maybe pedal width is somewhat
important for this virginica and maybe
the second most important attribute and
you can see you know Supple with is not
very important at all and you can see
how different pairings of attributes
also have some importance so this is
quite a handy tool for doing some
analysis on your on your input features
that's the end of this notebook uh you
know thank you for thank you for your
attention I appreciate it and yeah
um are there any questions
important
stop showing my screen because